continuing our video series covering the
ulti bugs Norway chest list tournament
we move on to round five with Sergey
Karjakin taking on the world champ with
the white pieces and that was I was the
funniest moment perhaps the entire
Norway's chess event pretty funny stuff
there I did the rumor is that Vladimir
Kramnik who you just saw there laughing
shook up the water bottle before Carlson
came to the table first of all that's
just awesome and why can't we have more
crazy pranks like that secondly it was
it was a good that Magnus took it in
stride and didn't stress about it taking
the time to wipe things down I guess fee
day is not going to punish him here for
starting his game a little late you know
given the a lot of it chromic was kind
of the cause of that but either way they
do eventually shake hands
Magnus starts the clock and we are off
ladies and gentlemen d4 was played
Magnus takes his time to adjust his
pieces not not the same opening that we
saw them place so many times at the
World Championship not going to be a
reuleaux PES and Carlson place the Dutch
obviously cariocans going to play my
personal favourite efore the Staunton
gambit come on no he plays g3 like a
good Russian schoolboy quickly we get
Knight f6 Bishop g2 and East six Magnus
preparing to head into the stone ball
playing East six rather than g6 which
would be a Leningrad Dutch after c4s
played Magnus quickly plays d5 Knight to
b2 all things are standard the bishop
comes to d6 developing behind the strong
pawn structure and Sergei plays the
first slightly unexpected development
the knight coming to h3 rather than f3
both sides record Roca Magnus brings out
the knight to c6 and the game is on this
is pretty typical but I don't see six is
really not that misplaced normally you
think of not blocking the C pawn but
this Bishop is going to find a home over
here and this night sometimes relocates
to e7 or even a5 so if you're thinking
that's a little bit weird it's not that
weird III we get b6 quickly by Magnus
playing very fast in round five here and
Sergei plays b3 himself the queenside
expansion is key because it'll make the
bishop on a6 that much more comfortable
right not not open to any threats on the
file but all things being
the truth is these structures do tend to
favor white as you can see the engine
tends to like white in these positions
just a slight edge you know mainly
because the potential weaknesses on the
light squares this bishop is a very very
good piece and should create some nice
tactics from writing on the diagonal
that's the kind of thing that Sergei was
looking for in the game and even though
there were some critical moments we'll
get to it is should be noted as an
instructive aspect for everybody at home
just how much you need to be aware of
potential tactics on this diagonal
Magnus plays Bishop a6 aware of the
tactics himself but feeling like he can
risk it no immediate pressure coming to
the d5 pawn given that this Knight can't
develop the c3 Sergei brings the knight
into f4 very very natural move get the
night off of the edge of the board poke
it a week east six pawn with tempo
pretty much living a dream here is
surrogate Kuryakin and in a nice
comfortable chair to go with it Magnus
has to part with the bishop pair but the
key is that he immediately inserts the
knight in to e4 to follow it up this is
important because normally this is a
huge sin to open the e-file here create
potential for that rook to have a ton of
nice open squares and again if this East
six pawn becomes a main feature of the
position it's going to be better for
white than black because that's not a
very healthy e6 pawn but Magnus is able
to put the knight on e4 and then what
you're going to see over the next few
moves with Sergei playing rook e1 is the
critical decision is surrounding right
here right now with how to deal with
this Knight we know this pawn is weak we
know we want to open this diagonal do we
trade do we play f3 to kind of kick the
knight and then try to gang up on the
pawn Sergei place the move rookie free
but I'm going to pause here and show you
that probably this is where he missed
his one chance to really convert on the
edge as the engine is saying he should
have taken on e4 and after F takes comes
a key idea key tactical idea f3 just
give up the c4 pawn and open up this
Bishop on this diagonal with reckless
abandonment some example of tactics that
might occur is after C takes b3 white
can even play the move e5 but even just
taking back on b3 we see a an awesome
Center here a very very dangerous Bishop
and a position that white is I think
much more comfortable playing for an
edge avoiding all the tack
the Magnus was able to generate in the
game Sergei played rookie free and then
Magnus play Queen to d7 and I think
Sergei played rookie 3 with the thought
that he could still play f3 and keep
that rook open but after Queen to d7
guarding tonight he kind of realized
maybe he needed to trade here maybe
wishes he even did it the move before
and succumbs to playing it now as you
can see he just captured on e4 Magnus
immediately captured back this this
whole idea of playing up three while
still the positional just sort of the
move that all strong chess players know
playing against the Dutch because you
want to pry open the light squares you
want to get this bishop in the game you
want to get access to that King on g8
it's it's key that he knows this is the
idea and so he plays up three anyway but
the big difference just that single
tempo he lost allows magnets to go for
these same lines with DC 4 takes e4 and
now Magnus takes on beat free as you saw
he just played and the difference is
that already right here right now the
edges is slipping it's slipping for
white big time because this d4 pawn is
going to become a target in a way that
it wasn't before 1 because with the
Queen on d8 there were no chances for a
move like rook a to d8 number 2 with the
Queen on d7 she actually guards the
knight again making white tactics a
little bit less powerful so Sergei is
sort of put on the spot here in terms of
how to approach the current position you
can take on b3 with 3 pieces right I
mean you've got the the rook the Queen
and the pawn
there's also moves to consider like d5
but in the end he actually sorry and the
end he actually goes for d5 that's right
probably probably safer was to take on
on on b3 but he goes for d5 hoping to
generate controversy that opens up this
bishop and again would create some
tactics but after captures and now takes
b3 taking advantage of the pin that
critical tempo again that he lost just
by playing rookie free and not having
the brick honey one having played 94 in
f3 earlier as I highlighted is going to
make a big difference in two ways one
he's down a move because the Queen is
here and 2 the rook is going to
constantly come under fire here Magnus
to point out all those things I'm saying
finds a great idea to take advantage of
that by sacrificing this a4 pawn and
immediately following that move with a
super super I guess sneaky
discovered attack you might describe it
as he slides this Bishop over to f1
unleashing the rook on a8 to get a
discovered attack on the Queen and
really the key point is regardless of
where that Queen goes the elimination of
this Bishop on g2 is is kind of where
the gloves will always come off in these
and for white in these in these Dutch
positions Mangus plays Knight a5 a super
nice tactic bringing the knight in to c4
and exposing the fact that as I said the
rook on e3 is undefended something it
would not be if it was still anyone so
in hindsight again as we wait here for
Sergei to move
he eventually plays for up to C tree
even rook to d3 I would fail - tactics
with Knight to c4 you can check it out
but I actually analyzed some lines with
rook takes e4 Brooke takes d5 and queen
to c6 that also would have been pretty
hard for Sergei so rook tv3 was really
not that much better he plays rook c3
magnus plays d4 and after E 5 he finds a
well a super creative way again to
expose not only that he's eliminated
White's LightSquared Bishop but that
this King is on an open diagonal rook
takes c4 would simply not be possible
everybody winning on the spot
is it fair to say Sergei missed this
move Knight c4 probably but the truth is
this position is already coming undone
having to slide the rook over for
protection and to block the diagonal
gives black the time to resupport that
pawn on d4 quick moves are made as white
is trying to defend things but Magnus is
already in super aggressive mode if you
have to put your King on h3 and there's
rooks coming into the game you uh you
know you got problems and here Magnus
shows exactly that rook lifting up Queen
to f3 doesn't miss his chance to convert
Shirley surrogates happiness King didn't
get mated but in order to avoid that he
had to allow this be pawn to run the
bishop came to e3
Guiteau was pushed and after rook t1 the
Brooke came down to d3 Sergei already
could have resigned here but he plays
one more attacking move for good measure
and simply throws in the towel he's
going to lose the bishop on e3 all
things are pin so the critical moment
again just as we did before to highlight
probably for white to have an advantage
was back here where Sergei could have
taken on e4 and then played for this f3
tactic immediately before black
that optimal time to coordinate but the
truth is after that Magnus put on a
display of accuracy that we know he does
really really like this a4 idea followed
by the discovered attack just from the
positional perspective of how important
it is to eliminate that LightSquared
bishop and he really never looked back
tactics are coming in this night is is
feeling super happy White's pieces are
feeling uncoordinated and just out of
place the tactics ensued and Magnus
converted like we said Sergei is happy
not to get mated but okay you're not
getting made it anymore with rook aged
six but you're going to have to lose a
piece because my D pawn is too strong so
fun stuff to see what happened when
these two played thank you for checking
out this video please subscribe to our
Channel and look for another video
coming out this week as we continue to
cover Magnus Carlson's journey at the
ulti bucks Norway chest Super blitz
tournament